hey guys my name is Jeff I'm Dan and
please ignore the camera reflection it's
right here
yeah we've also dropped all illusion
that we don't film this day's news and
Thursday's years on the same day wearing
the same clothes it's it's still Friday
in Australia but that's okay because
you've got the top five stories of the
week four year might has ten if for some
reason with Assassin's Creed origins
coming up you've just decided you want
to play a really crappy looking
Assassin's grade and I don't mean the
way the first one lost on 360 I mean
even worse someone has made that but it
made a PS 1d make the first Assassin's
Creed which is I wonder what is it ah
well this is something that this used in
98 d make seems to be doing is kind of
his shtick sorry he's also done d makes
for games like fluff for lots of us in
GTA 5 basically it looks like it runs on
the ps1 but a lot of you guys have said
you think it looks even worse than that
judge for yourself you're watching it
right now it also has a ps1 style
soundtrack to go along with those I'm
very poly Glenny visuals but yeah a
little bit of fun for you to week we're
back at e3 but we didn't witness the
most powerful console ever made we don't
have the t-shirt not a person not a
person we heard about it it was a broom
and whispers all through the girl
through the holes
it looks like the Xbox one it isn't
gonna be able to run 4k 60 frames per
second games very easily just according
to digital founder who released a very
very comprehensive report so in it they
they tested nine games but games that
have shipped in games that are yet to
come out yeah and it looks like games
that run at 720p to 900 P a really
really Hardware intensive to up raise to
4k yeah where is games that run at 1080p
a little bit run a lot better at 4k on
the Xbox one X it's most likely that the
techniques that I'm going to be used to
upscale those are going to be
checkerboarding or dynamic resolution
much like the ps4 Pro yeah so I don't
know if that's something you're into but
you can check out our breakdown of the
whole report over on GameSpot all the
full report over at digital foundry so
Activision obviously recognizes that
destiny was a massive success but it
turns out there are some things they
wanted to work on that they felt like
they kind of failed that with the first
game
want to fix it with a second and one of
those is having a constant stream of new
content right so they felt like they
didn't meet demand
last time according to CEO Eric
Hirschbeck so basically he said that
even though you know the expansions that
they did bring out they were happy with
and they weren't bringing them out as
often as they wanted to so they want to
fix that with destiny too and what
they're what they have done is they've
brought on more studios including hi
moon who worked on the Transformers
games and Vicarious Visions who of
course do Skylanders so the hope is that
they'll be working with the central
Bungie team to produce even more content
for the game and so that demand can be
met and this time around the baby is
also really soon July 18th ps4 and July
19 for Xbox one souls are coming to PC
in late August so don't worry PC gamers
they have long forgotten about you so
this week in Nintendo news and tenders
still trying to figure out how to get $2
damn it
well somehow they haven't figured it out
even though you're all buying switches
and no one can get that goddamn hands on
one
but in mobile games seems like Super
Mario run wasn't as successful as they
planned it had over a hundred and fifty
million downloads a lot which is a huge
amount but only 10% of those actually
paid to unlock the full game yes so
basically it was like a free to play
system for like I think the first ten
levels and then if you wanted more than
that you had to dish out like 10 bucks
which is like a fairly significant
amount of money that I think mobile
gamers perhaps weren't used to buy it
pain into comparison Fire Emblem Heroes
which recently came out has below one
tenth of the downloads of Super Mario
run but it's brought in more revenue
seems like they've learned from those
two examples they can all apply the best
monetization system to their next game
which is gonna be Animal Crossing on
mobile which I'm excited about mix out
the build the town yes that's cool I
happy home designs one of my favorite
pastimes here at GameSpot
is to look at that comic section and
really enjoy the user names people come
up with some of my favorites are blue
tube triple one okay
nah-nah head he's a good one too but
another one that I also like that I came
across this week he is stallion 83
mm-hmm and stallion 83 actually had a
pretty big week for the last decade he's
had the highest game of school on Xbox
Live and this week he gave that all up
full of OS X according to him it
this ain't the right pops who is selling
a 93 was overtaken by Steve Monroe or
smear off this week to one and a half
million gamerscore
yeah they're both Orville one and a half
and I'd say by now I mean this happened
earlier in the week SM row of however
you say it must be over like 1.6 now but
then efforts still darling ahead I mean
even though it's dalian 83 was on his
honeymoon galleon ting he's still
playing a lot of games as well but uh
what what I love is that the dude who
took over and who now has the highest
gamer score has said he was not trying
to gun for the highest gamer score like
it would and that was not in his plan at
all kind of just happened and also he
won't be applying for the Guinness World
Records title to take it from Ray Cox
who has had it for the last decade right
nice that's really well Mike yeah
goodbye and good luck there is no more
games fun news for this week that's
right but it's alright we'll be back on
Monday but until then we hope you have
an excellent weekend do let us know what
you cared about this week what you saw
today stories and anything you want to
see on the show we'll see you guys bye